our next guest is an award-winning
many times over actress who we all fell
in love with um in such hits as oh
sisterhood of the traveling pants the
girl i mean
literally me and my daughters we love
that movie so much and they're all like
friends still and it's just the greatest
thing ever um ugly betty i mean come on
she won every award for that
oh and just her hit show superstore also
i mean everything she touches turns to
gold
but it's because she has a hand in it
she's an executive producer and director
her current series is hentafide which is
now in season two on netflix please
welcome
the incomparable america ferreira
i mean
like how old were you when selma hayek
discovered you for ugly betty well i was
when i did uh started ugly betty i was
21 but i actually began my career at 17
with a film called real women have
curves of course which was very
accoladed it was a beautiful beautiful
film but i think you started earlier
than that
in theater which caused some sibling
rivalry
yes i'm the youngest of six children all
of my siblings were like in band and
when it came around for me to join you
know an activity i didn't want to do
band i wanted to do theater but my two
older sisters were going to the
school-wide auditions for romeo and
juliet that were open to everybody and
they were just going because they wanted
to like hang out with cute boys and
their friends
and i was in third grade and so i said i
want to go i want to go to the auditions
and my sisters were like now you can't
come you're too little and my mom was
like you have to take her so like fine
they're like fine but you have to sit in
the back and you have to shut up and so
so i was like fine whatever and then
before they knew it i literally like
just grabbed
the script and like was on stage
auditioning and then ended up getting a
better part than them so they were very
mad at me and they didn't let me go to
the wrap party which is still trauma
deep down in my bones
how do you deal with that now as adults
i go to all the wrap parties
and then i tell them they're not invited
but when you did
can i ask you about that first audition
when
the person was asking you to speak in a
certain way it really spoke to me that
story yeah
yeah i started auditioning when i was
around like 16 years old and my very
first audition was just like a
commercial audition and remember i came
in i did it and then um and then the
casting director asked me to do it again
but this time can you try to sound more
latina
and i was like okay and i did it exactly
the same way because i had no idea what
she was talking about and then i went
home and then it took me a moment to
realize like
oh she wanted me to like speak in broken
english and i was so confused because
i am a latina so this is what a latina
sounds like you know and and i didn't i
i realized right away at the beginning
of my career that i didn't fit into
her projection or stereotypes of what
latinas are and so you know i have been
deeply insanely fortunate to have the
opportunities i've had to play these
beautiful amazing roles that have
transcended any kind of niche stereotype
or audience but my career is an anomaly
it is a miracle and it shouldn't be
because there is so much talent out
there in our community and it's talent
that deserves opportunity so to
but i think why it does relate to people
and and why it shouldn't be like oh well
they're just actresses and what are they
complaining about is that the way we are
treated is is an indication of how our
entire culture thinks about us as
individuals our ethnicities our whatever
our marginalized communities that we
come from are and it is it is just like
it's the tip of the iceberg because it's
so deeply entrenched those thoughts and
those ideas in our culture that they
think it's okay to say that right and
and so no it's not new i just watched
this incredible documentary on on rita
moreno's career yes it's called just a
girl who decided to go for it oh my god
i
wept and cried watching it and and to
see what she went through
the roles she had to take what she had
to swallow the sexual assault that she
experienced in her career and people are
just like suck it up that's that's the
biz and obviously we're at a time now
where where we are calling those things
out and saying it's not acceptable for
any of us to have to to live that way
and and and stay silent about it and so
so yeah you know and all of that to say
to get to make a show like hentaified
where our community is being portrayed
in complex human ways that yes there are
difficult issues but also
we have joy and we deserve to have joy
and we deserve to have love and laughter
and humor and so what an honor to be
this far into my career getting to
create space for those kinds of stories
to be told when i just didn't have that
growing up and there's a billboard in
times square
right now
we have a vision of it yes we do
[Applause]
[Music]